tout à l'heure vous faites des
sous-entendus et je ne comprends rien
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné il ya
quand même eu une réinterprétation d'une
vidéo avec entre autres un échange mais
c'est un échange
alors concrètement c'est quoi soyons
factuel c'est de la drogue excusez moi
ce que vous dites
excusez moi je termine sur le score donc
moi ce que j'entends c'est michel éclair
en fait on alors j'ai toujours pas
compris l'histoire de me rend triste
mais je n'ai pas compris on s'en fout
nord en réalité michel éclair est un
trafiquant de drogue qui avait de la
drogue sur lui
il finit la péniche aménagée dans les
deux corps mallory steux appelez ça
comment abandonner qu'est ce qu'ils ont
sur un truc et les téléspectateurs 10
pareil sur les réseaux sociaux il se
doit avant qu'on clôture sur cette
affaire et sur les moyens
j'aimerais qu'on nous dit si un début un
milieu une fin qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pour vous voilà comme ça pourrait pas
dire je vous ai pas d c'est la parole
khalid contrôle de police alors donc
mais on reprend michel des clercs et
dans la rue il se passe quoi contrôle de
police d'accord il a pas de masque il
sentait une odeur de cannabis
d'accord il le contrôle à leicester de
la rue c'est clair recul
le collègue rentrer avec lui on sait pas
qui pousse qui tirent les trois autres
arrivent et c'est de le sortir pour
l'interpeller parce qu'ils sont à
l'interpellation d'accord oui donc voilà
qui restent dans la rue parce qu'il
voulait pas rentrer maintenant il le
tire il le tire de l'homme l'interpellé
faux frais sur lui a tant qui le tire
ensuite éclair referme la porte et là il
se retrouve enfermé avec lui et lui fait
110 kg il se met en boule
donc c'est très compliqué et l'envoie
ils n'ont porté aucun coup à ce moment
là donc il essaie il c'est de l'attrapé
il essaye c'est de l'interpeller donc il
n'y arrive pas il n'y arrive pas en
suisse est clair arrive à ouvrir la
porte et il appelle ses amis peut
comprendre qu'on prenne à mon avis
encore une fois le but que les il ya
neuf familles en bas qui vont arriver
ils vont hélas les premiers coups
commencent moi je pense que le collègue
entend les neuf jade montée est donc là
il arrive et il porte des coups
maintenant si vous portez des coûts pour
comment comment juste pour commander
violences policières illégitimes mais là
est ce que c'est le cas est-ce que c'est
légitime ou pas ce qu'ils veulent
l'interpeller
ils veulent eux le bloqué ils veulent
donc ils se retrouvent avec lui ensuite
il ya le policier qui bloque la porte
qui bloque la porte et aboie ce qu'il
avait dit la veille il avait de la
drogue sur l'iss et ça c'est une
hypothèse c'est une fois nommé d'abord
il avait
on a retrouvé du cannabis d'accord une
hypothèse non ça c'est pas une hypothèse
on attend des réponses concernant
retrouver du canal trafiquants oui
pardon consommateurs c'est pas trafic
c'est lui moi c'est une contravention
ici sinon sur la première semaine passée
c'est un pour le rhume avoir le cannabis
est une contravention mais non non ça a
changé d'avoir à changer quelques mois
c'est plus un délit c'est une contre à
mon nom mais maintenant voyons s'il est
pas récidiviste en plus les
multirécidivistes l'aps que la prison
terminé donc bruno donc dumas donc du
coup mes collègues se trouve enfermé
avec lui le collègue la lui porte des
coups il entend du monde qui arrive à
mon avis de le sécher de dire voilà
maintenant il faut que ces chiffres
c'est de la violence oui mais nous
l'avions c'est notre quotidien
donc il faut sécher le mec il faut
pouvoir interpeller il faut pouvoir le
neutraliser pour ensuite le sortirai
l'exfiltrer c'est une intervention de
police qui me semble plutôt classique